des référendums sont certes organisés
mais difficile de se dire que la volonté
des habitants sera respectée que pense
d'ailleurs les Ukrainiens dans
l'ensemble de ce référendum
je pense que les Ukrainiens voient ces
référendum comme une
tactique complètement orchestré par le
Kremlin pour justifier d'une élection de
ces territoires un peu comme ce qu'elle
a fait en Crimée en 2014 où elle avait
organisé un référendum alors qu'il y
avait des hommes armés sur la péninsule
avec très peu de temps de préparation et
ensuite annoncer un résultat de 97% en
faveur de rejoindre la Russie ici les le
temps a été encore plus bref les
référendums ont été annoncés à un délai
de seulement trois jours à un moment où
sur l'ensemble de la ligne de front qui
sépare le territoire contre les para
l'Ukraine au territoire contre les par
la Russie dans ces régions il y a des
combats et ou même si des données
sociologiques sont impossibles à obtenir
en ce moment il semble assez clair que
la résistance à l'occupation russe et
forte particulièrement dans les régions
de zapporisa et Herson dans le sud mais
même très probablement dans l'est aussi
dans les régions de Luans même si une
partie de ces régions a été facto sous
contrôle russe depuis 2014 puisque si on
peut prendre la région de harkit qui les
voisines comme un exemple on a très bien
pu voir ces derniers jours combien des
gens habitant les territoires qui ont
été occupés par la Russie dans cette
région ont clairement une position très
procrainienne et aucune envie de
rejoindre la Russie ce n'est pas le cas
de tout le monde mais c'est le cas d'une
très grande partie je pense des gens
dans cette région et les Ukrainiens ne
doutent pas que si les Russes avaient pu
garder le contrôle de la région de harki
ils auraient probablement éventuellement
essayer d'organiser un référendum ici
aussi à un moment donné s'il s'était
cité à suivre
à prendre cette cette voix univers où on
est la